the power
[Music]
this
hey I don't want you to hit him on my
chicken cheese for jet here is that so
it's an IV Christian I'd appreciate it
but if you relax you would get it I know
that she's dying there you can go more
yen right and you can still get it and
move it when your Center I got this bob
bobbi's to it
yeah this is just a still dozen bodies
don't start milking the drill again
you're not supposed to come out with
your hands like this so that he can do
the drill you have a you have a your
your elbows are too big they're not real
strike you got it
so he become hot so the city does not do
anything I know start milking this one
okay so there's something we can don't
give it up here move oh don't give me
[Music]
good
Hey
he's gonna do that so when he comes up
he comes up oh he knows out
we'll follow it
notice how and she goes yeah you see on
going on
you see no sale here like this
you lost connection even with him box
with him you see like him back he turned
that way I turn this way
you see inside off with him out other
side
[Music]
let's go you will not be able to hit
their neck but your body should not have
gone go to the back you might you go hit
them in the frickin app you get it gives
you a more realistic thing so I'll go
I'll go
so when I go like this my mind should be
that I'm coming in yes ok so what's
happening this weekend
Lucas mind is being pulled by the throat
my fault
by my you get you know what happens as
you change the energy well there's a
couple things one we're not learning the
energy for that technique into you're
not training your display your
commitment the things that lead to other
greater things I have to give you an
assignment and then you want to stick to
it whether you are afraid or not okay
right now the mindful is your mind
because you afraid that's Frank I've
never any attention
have you texted stop with you on the
mouth
so the beginner gets cold hit the target
I think they like this and then we kill
them in the technique it's the mind I
want you to hold you so I am give you
the target with my mind but my arm stays
on the target is not cannot do something
and something else yes is the same here
to be can't be I touch them you go and I
go that's not musubi okay
keep Kyushu be answer this there it is
it's intention intention connection do
you see if I if I wait to feel it even
that's gonna be too late okay I have to
feel it on the inside on the inside oh
you see how your life but you can't stop
because your phone it looks like a book
doesn't it doesn't it okay like he's
come here because here he goes again
again
well the way you get caught go you see
okay I'll always connection connection
connection it doesn't matter where I am
on the outside that's it
okay so the worst thing you can do is
tell yourself that second okay when you
say get second revenue of NOK captain
don't diss it go for for us okay space
on cross mini plane okay so he's testing
strike like this it's coming in and
you're like pushing it out that's the
only one plane you see all moving there
like this redirecting look is extending
it push it
extending it behind you see from the
rotation from the rotation and while I
always set extended behind me guess
where I am going in front of it it's
weird okay so don't stay over here I'm
gonna move inside your arms whoosh hey
let's go
pick it up okay you're jacking up our
noggins let's go
[Music]
so I have developed already of a
relationship with you we already United
you get okay so I want every out nice
it's not people's and then I do
something we'll already connected
already already in it already you see
okay he's you can't get that okay so
combinedly what you have to do is how do
i generate so I'm going to go on you get
that well I'll work some people are
still big mother skill you shaking above
Indonesian okay so how do I get a
connection this is it's a spiritual
thing is this
and that reviews on some bees there's a
strong fee then there's a space between
you or not do you get it
fear makes the space because here today
is I in realize are in crazy space
because of the light forces me to be
reactionary after yourself
so how did we get around reactionary
problem we unite
you're not ahead of me I'm not behind
you how there's no you and there's no me
so what's it look like he goes go is how
a movie
you see this is you guys you guys yeah
so making it part of the game
now same thing
this is no difference
this is still team you see this step I
can't even it's not this is we're
connected right here will connect okay
so is it right here okay I generate
enough friction or I can move okay I
mean same thing his strike is exactly
when I move means do you see it's not
what my move does not want or monster
saw he he's striking and this is exactly
there's that he should not and it's the
same thing he goes and this is exactly
what this truck is you see it when it
hit they go together feel it you see
it's not here
boom
okay so here's why my direction start
simple start connected this is how we
did the first thing is hang up my
mistress how how would when I come up
where he goes over you see how I went do
I turn it's his turn it's he's turning
my goes this way he's turning it I'm
turning up inside so here's how to do on
the bottom and you go up in MA
forget you want the oneness
for far far far then we left
this man
[Music]
[Applause]
projection non-phonetic it's not reject
you or coming in do you understand so
this time
yeah yes projection the to work together
project you stop coming in okay and
friction just here IP friction distinct
IP friction you see like here we go I'm
right here here
I see friction no fault i friction and
in yon projection
not true Yong it's not true you Hey